- [Moshe] So tell me,
what are the Pink Pistols?
- Pink Pistols is a national
LGBT self-defense organization,
we are heavily focused on
training the LGBT community
in armed and unarmed
self-defense.
- Why did you first
purchase a gun?
- For a lot of people, Orlando
made individuals question,
do I need a firearm
for self-defense?
- People wouldn't have died
if someone was
there and had a gun.
- There's no guarantee, but it
would have changed the odds.
- When seconds count,
the police are often
minutes or hours away.
A 100 pound female has a chance
against four linebackers,
if she's carrying.
- Seems like an oddly
specific situation,
four linebackers,
one 100 pound girl,
and then she'll pick up a,
I don't know how guns work,
so I guess it's
something like this?
- (laughing)
Something like that.
- Kkrah-kkrah-kkrah-kkrah!
And then, the equalizer.
Would you consider
yourselves politically
liberal, conservative,
or neither?
- My views are probably
some of the ones that
line up with the gays
from the 60s and 70s,
where it's like, hey man, look,
Mom and Dad kicked you out,
no one wants you, you're gonna
have to move to the city kid,
and you're on your own, but--
- This is the opening scene
from Rent, is that right?
- Yes it is, that's right.
- How does it go?
- [All] ♪ 525,600 minutes
- ♪ The cops will take
to get to your door
(laughing)
♪ That's why I own a gun
What do liberals not
understand about gun ownership?
- If someone is living
in an area that is safe,
or they perceive to be
relatively crime-free,
that's a very elitist attitude,
to define how someone
chooses to defend themselves.
- To be a gun owner is
not supporting violence.
It is an identity.
- So Second Amendment
in gun control issues
is really an issue
of identity politics.
- Strangely, yes.
- Was it harder to come
out as a gun owner,
or as a queer person?
- I feel more accepted as a
gay guy in the gun community,
than a gun owner in
the gay community.
- Why don't we try it?
You come out to
me as gun owners.
- All right, so,
something really important
I gotta tell you.
- Cool, man, I'm your bro, dude!
- So I need you to understand,
I own 15 guns.
- Whatja say what, bro?
- I own 15 guns.
(retching)
Get out of my house!
- I wish that wasn't as
accurate as it often is.
(laughing)
- Okay, we've been
through some good times
and some bad times,
and some weird times,
- (laughing) Yeah, Amsterdam!
- There is a part of me
that I have been hiding
from you, and I--
- Chris, there is one
thing that you could say
that would make me
stop loving you,
and there's no way, there's
no way it's true of you.
- I am a gun owner.
- Don't say you're a
gun owner, oh,
that was the thing!
- (bleep)
- It was the one thing!
All right Piper.
- So Moshe, there's something
that I've been
wanting to tell you.
I'm a gun owner.
- (gasps) Oohh, Piper,
hell no, hell to the no,
to the no, Piper, to
the no, no no no no no,
no no no no no no
(laughter)
no no no no!
♪ 565,600 minutes
Hoo, Piper, hoo Piper, Piper!
I love you no matter what.
- Thank you.
(laughter)